Me gustaría hablar hoy de dos grandes tendencias sociales del siglo venidero
y quizá de los próximos 10,000 años.
Voy a empezar con mi trabajo sobre el amor romántico
ya que es mi más reciente trabajo.
Lo que mis colegas y yo hicimos fue poner a 32 personas locamente enamoradas
en un escáner funcional IRM
De esas personas, 17 estaban locamente enamoradas y correspondidas
y 15 locamente enamoradas y despechadas.
Entonces hablaré sobre eso primero
y luego ahondaré sobre a dónde creo que se dirige el amor.
Shakespeare decía: "¿Qué es esto del amor?"
Creo que nuestros ancestros, los seres humanos se han estado haciendo esta pregunta
desde hace un millón de años cuando se sentaron o tiraron alrededor de sus fogatas y miraban las estrellas.
Mi intención inicial fue entender qué era el amor romántico
examinando los últimos 45 años de investigación en... sólo en investigación psicológica,
y resulta que existe un grupo específico de cosas que ocurren cuando uno se enamora.
La primero que sucede es lo que llamo cuando
una persona empieza a tomar "un significado especial."
Como alguna vez me dijo un camionero:
"El mundo tiene un nuevo centro y ese centro se llama Mary Anne."
George Bernard Shaw lo dijo ligeramente diferente, dijo:
"El amor consiste en sobrestimar las diferencias entre una mujer y otra."
Y en efecto eso es lo que hacemos (risas).
Entonces enfocas tu atención en esta persona.
Puedes enlistar lo que no te gusta de ellos,
pero entonces haces eso a un lado y te enfocas en lo que estás haciendo.
Como dijo Chaucer: "El amor es ciego."
Al tratar de entender el amor romántico,
decidí que leería poesía de todo el mundo,
así que quisiera recitarles un breve poema chino del siglo VIII,
porque es un ejemplo casi perfecto de un hombre que está totalmente enfocado en una mujer en particular.
Es un poco parecido a cuando estás perdidamente enamorado de alguien
y caminas en el estacionamiento;
su auto es diferente de los demás en el estacionamiento,
su copa de vino en la cena es diferente de cualquiera de las demás copas de la cena.
En este caso, el hombre se quedó prendado del tapete de bambú para dormir.
Y dice así, el hombre se llama Yuan Chen:
"Es intolerable guardar el tapete de bambú para dormir,
cuando la noche que te traje a casa, te vi desenvolverlo."
Se quedó prendado del tapete de bambú,
probablemente a causa de la elevada actividad de la dopamina en su cerebro,
al igual que ocurre con ustedes y conmigo.
Como sea, esta persona no sólo cobra un significado especial,
uno enfoca su atención en ella.
La engrandeces y tienes mucha energía.
Como dijo un polinesio: "Siento que estoy saltando en el cielo."
Estás despierto toda la noche, caminas hasta el amanecer;
sientes una euforia intensa cuando las cosas van bien,
el ánimo se vuelve una horrible desesperación cuando las cosas van mal,
se vuelve una verdadera dependencia de esta persona.
Como me dijo un hombre de negocios neoyorquino: "Me gusta todo lo que a ella le gusta."
Simple, el amor romántico es muy simple.
Te vuelves sexualmente posesivo en extremo.
Cuando tienes sexo casual con alguien…
no te importa si se está acostando con alguien más.
Pero en el momento en que te enamoras,
te vuelves sexualmente posesivo en extremo de ellos.
Yo pienso que esto tiene un propósito darwiniano.
El meollo de esto es unir a dos personas con la
fuerza suficiente para empezar a criar bebés en equipo.
Las características principales del amor romántico son ansia:
un ansia intensa de estar con una persona en particular, no sólo en lo sexual, también en lo emocional.
Preferirías... estaría bien ir a la cama juntos,
pero lo que quieres es que te llame, te invite a salir, etcétera.
Que te diga que te ama.
La otra característica principal es la motivación,
el motor de tu cerebro empieza a arrancar y quieres a esa persona.
Por último, pero no por eso menos importante, es una obsesión.
Antes de poner a estas personas en la máquina IRM,
les hago todo tipo de preguntas;
pero mi pregunta más importante es siempre la misma:
"¿qué porcentaje del día y la noche piensas en esa persona?"
Y en efecto contestan: "Todo el día, toda la noche, no dejo de pensar en él o ella."
Entonces la pregunta final que les hago,
siempre me tengo que preparar para esta pregunta,
ya que no soy psicóloga
no trabajo con gente que tenga cualquier trauma.
Y mi pregunta final, que siempre es la misma, es:
"¿Morirías por él o por ella?"
Y de hecho contestan con un "¡Sí!"
como si hubiera pedido que me pasaran la sal.
Simplemente me deja estupefacta.
Entonces escaneamos sus cerebros, cuando miran la foto de sus enamorados y luego una foto neutral,
con una tarea de distracción de por medio.
Pudimos hallar… viendo el mismo cerebro en su estado exaltado
y en su estado en reposo,
hallamos actividad en muchas regiones del cerebro.
De hecho, una de las más importantes fue una región cerebral
que se activa cuando sientes el subidón de la cocaína.
Y de hecho eso es exactamente lo que sucede.
Empecé a darme cuenta que el amor romántico no es una emoción,
es más, siempre había pensado que era una serie de emociones,
de muy intensas a muy bajas.
Pero en realidad es un impulso, originado en el motor de la mente,
de la parte de la mente que desea, que ansía.
El tipo de mente, la parte de la mente,
como cuando tomas esa pieza de chocolate,
cuando quieres ganar una promoción en el trabajo.
El motor de la mente. Es un impulso.
De hecho pienso que es más poderoso que el impulso sexual.
Cuando le preguntas a alguien si se acostaría contigo y te dicen: "No, gracias,"
ciertamente no te suicidas y no te hundes en una depresión clínica.
Pero ciertamente, en todo el mundo, la gente despechada mataría por amor.
La gente vive por amor, mata por amor, muere por amor,
hay canciones, poemas, novelas, esculturas, pinturas, mitos y leyendas.
En más de 175 sociedades, la gente ha dejado evidencias de este poderoso sistema cerebral.
He llegado a pensar que es uno de los sistemas cerebrales más poderosos en la Tierra
tanto para nuestro júbilo como para nuestra desgracia.
Y he llegado a pensar que es uno de los tres
sistemas cerebrales básicamente diferentes que evolucionaron del apareamiento y la reproducción.
Uno es el impulso sexual, el deseo de gratificación sexual.
W.H. Auden la llamó "la comezón neural intolerable,"
y en efecto eso es.
Te molesta un poco todo el tiempo, como tener hambre.
El segundo de estos tres sistemas cerebrales es el amor romántico:
esa euforia, esa obsesión del amor fresco.
Y el tercer sistema cerebral es el apego:
la sensación de calma y seguridad que puedes sentir con una pareja a largo plazo.
Y creo que el impulso sexual evolucionó para llevarnos ahí,
buscando toda una gama de parejas.
Puedes sentirlo cuando estás manejando tu auto.
Puede enfocarse en nadie.
Creo que el amor romántico evolucionó para permitirte enfocar tu energía de apareamiento
en un solo individuo a la vez,
y de esa forma conservar tiempo y energía de apareamiento.
Y creo que el apego, el tercer sistema cerebral,
evolucionó para permitirte tolerar a ese ser humano (risas),
al menos el tiempo suficiente para criar a un niño juntos en equipo.
Con base a este preámbulo, quisiera discutir las dos tendencias sociales más profundas.
Una de los últimos 10,000 años y la otra, ciertamente de los últimos 25 años,
que van a tener un impacto en estos tres distintos sistemas cerebrales:
la lujuria, el amor romántico y el apego profundo a una pareja.
La primera es la mujer trabajadora, entrando a la fuerza de trabajo.
He analizado a 150... 130 sociedades usando los anuarios demográficos de las Naciones Unidas,
y en todas partes, en 129 de las 130, las mujeres no sólo están entrando al mercado del trabajo,
a veces muy lentamente, pero están entrando al mercado de trabajo,
y cerrando lentamente la brecha entre hombres y mujeres
en términos de poder económico, salud y educación.
Muy lentamente.
Por cada tendencia en el planeta, existe una contra tendencia.
Todos lo sabemos, pero... hay un antigua dicho árabe que dice:
"Los perros ladran pero las caravanas siguen avanzando"
y en efecto la caravana avanza.
Las mujeres están regresando al mercado de trabajo,
y digo regresando al mercado de trabajo, porque esto no es nuevo.
Durante millones de años, en los pastizales de África,
cuando las mujeres todo los días recolectaban sus verduras
llegaban a casa con el 60 u 80 por ciento de la cena.
La familia con doble ingreso era estándar,
y a las mujeres se les consideraba igual de poderosas que los hombres en lo sexual, en lo social y lo económico
En resumen, estamos avanzando hacia el pasado.
Por tanto, el peor invento de la mujer fue el arado.
Con el inicio de la agricultura usando arado, el rol del hombre se volvió poderoso en extremo.
Las mujeres perdieron sus antiguos trabajos como recolectoras,
pero entonces con las revoluciones industrial y postindustrial
están regresando al mercado laboral.
En resumen, están adquiriendo el estatus que tenían hace un millón de años,
hace 10,000 años, hace 100,000 años.
Estamos viendo una de las tradiciones más notables en la historia del animal humano
y va a tener un impacto.
En general doy una conferencia completa sobre el impacto de la mujer en la comunidad de negocios,
aquí sólo diré un par de cosas, y pasaré al sexo y al amor.
Existen muchas diferencias de género,
cualquiera que piense que hombres y mujeres son iguales simplemente nunca ha tenido un hijo y una hija.
No sé porqué quieren pensar esto de que los hombres y las mujeres son iguales.
Hay mucho en común, pero hay todo un montón de cosas que
no tienen en común.
Somos, en palabras de Ted Hughes:
"Creo que fuimos hechos para ser como dos pies, nos necesitamos mutuamente para salir adelante."
Pero no evolucionamos para tener el mismo cerebro.
Y cada vez encontramos más y más diferencias de género en el cerebro.
Mencionaré unas cuantas para continuar con el sexo y el amor.
Una de ellas es la habilidad verbal de la mujer, las mujeres sí que pueden hablar.
La habilidad de la mujer para encontrar la palabra correcta rápidamente, la articulación básica
sube a la mitad del ciclo menstrual, cuando los niveles de estrógeno alcanzan su pico;
aunque incluso en la menstruación, son mejores que el hombre promedio.
Las mujeres sí que pueden hablar.
cambio*: Lo han hecho por un millón de años, las palabras fueron herramientas de la mujer.
Sostuvieron a ese bebé enfrente de su cara,
halagándolo, reprimiéndolo, educándolo con palabras;
y en efecto, se convierten en una fuerza muy poderosa.
Incluso en lugares como la India y Japón,
donde las mujeres no están entrando rápidamente al mercado laboral normal,
están ingresando al periodismo.
Y creo que la televisión es como una fogata global,
nos sentamos alrededor de ella y moldea nuestras mentes.
Casi siempre, cuando estoy en la tele, los productores que me llaman
para negociar lo que voy a decir, son mujeres.
Es más, alguna vez Solzhenitsyn dijo:
"Tener un gran escritor es tener otro gobierno."
Hoy en día 54% de los escritores en Estados Unidos son mujeres.
Esta es una de muchísimas características que las mujeres tienen
que llevarán al mercado laboral.
Tienen habilidades increíbles, dotes de negociación,
son altamente imaginativas.
Hoy conocemos la circuitería cerebral de la imaginación, de la planeación a largo plazo;
tienden a los pensamientos interconectados,
porque las partes del cerebro femenino están mejor conectadas,
tienden a reunir más piezas de información cuando piensan,
los ponen en patrones más complejos, ven más opciones y consecuencias.
Tienden a ser contextuales, holísticas, lo que llamo pensadoras en red.
Los hombres tienden, en promedio, a desechar lo que consideran superfluo,
se enfocan en lo que hacen y se mueven en un patrón de pensamiento en pasos.
Ambas son formas de pensamiento perfectamente aceptables,
necesitamos ambas para seguir adelante.
De hecho, existen más genios hombres en el mundo.
Cuando…bueno también hay más idiotas hombres en el mundo (risas).
Cuando el cerebro masculino funciona bien, funciona extremadamente bien;
y lo que creo que estamos haciendo es movernos hacia una sociedad colaborativa,
una sociedad en la que los talentos tanto de hombres y mujeres se están empezando
a entender, valorar y emplear.
De hecho, la entrada de la mujer al mercado de trabajo está teniendo un enorme
impacto en el sexo, el romance y la vida familiar.
Antes que nada, las mujeres están empezando a expresar su sexualidad.
Siempre me sorprende cuando la gente viene y me pregunta:
¿por qué los hombres son tan adúlteros?
Les digo: "¿por qué creen que los hombres son más adúlteros que las mujeres?"
"Bueno ¡porque los hombres son más adúlteros!"
Les digo: "¿con quién creen que estos hombres se acuestan?"
¡Es aritmética elemental! (Risas)
Como sea,
en el mundo occidental, las jovencitas empiezan…
las mujeres despiertan más temprano al sexo, tienen más parejas,
expresan menos remordimiento que sus parejas,
se casan más tarde, tienen menos hijos, dejan malos matrimonios por tener buenos.
Estamos viendo el surgimiento de la expresión sexual femenina.
De hecho, una vez más nos estamos moviendo hacia el tipo de expresión sexual
que probablemente se vio en los pastizales africanos hace un millón de años,
porque este es el tipo de expresión sexual que vemos
en las sociedades recolectoras y cazadoras de la actualidad.
También estamos volviendo a una forma antigua de igualdad matrimonial,
Ahora dicen que el siglo XXI va a ser
el siglo de lo que llaman "el matrimonio simétrico"
ó el "matrimonio puro" o el "matrimonio amigable."
Este es el matrimonio entre iguales moviéndose hacia
un patrón que es altamente compatible con el antiguo espíritu humano.
También estamos viendo un crecimiento en el amor romántico,
91 por ciento de las estadounidenses y 86 por ciento de los estadounidenses
no se casarían con una pareja aunque tuviera todas las cualidades que buscan
si no estuvieran enamorados de la persona.
La gente alrededor del mundo, en un estudio de 37 sociedades
quiere estar enamorada de la persona con la que se casan.
En efecto, los matrimonios arreglados van de salida de la vida humana,
incluso creo que los matrimonios se pueden volver más estables
debido a la segunda gran tendencia mundial.
La primera es las mujeres entrando al mercado laboral,
la segunda el envejecimiento de la población mundial.
Dicen que ahora en los Estados Unidos,
los 85 años deberían ser considerados como la mediana edad,
porque en la parte alta de la categoría de 76 a 85 solamente…
tanto como el 40 por ciento de la gente no tiene ningún problema.
Así que estamos viendo una verdadera extensión de la mediana edad,
y para uno de mis libros, examiné los datos de divorcio de 58 sociedades.
Y resulta que, entre más viejo eres, es menos probable que te divorcies.
Entonces la tasa de divorcio en la actualidad es estable en los Estados Unidos
y de hecho ha empezado a declinar
Y quizás decline más.
Incluso agregaría que con el Viagra, el reemplazo de estrógenos, reemplazo de caderas
y las increíblemente interesantes mujeres,
las mujeres nunca habían sido tan interesantes como ahora;
en ninguna época en este planeta, las mujeres han sido tan educadas, tan interesantes, tan capaces.
Honestamente pienso que si en verdad hubo una época en la evolución humana
en que pudiéramos tener buenos matrimonios, esa época es el presente.
Sin embargo, no faltan cierto tipo de complicaciones en esto.
Estos tres sistemas cerebrales: lujuria, amor romántico y apego
no siempre van de la mano,
pueden hacerlo, por cierto.
Por eso el sexo casual no es tan casual,
con un orgasmo obtienes un pico de dopamina;
la dopamina está asociada con el amor romántico,
y puedes terminar enamorándote de la persona con quien tuviste sexo casual.
Con el orgasmo, entonces tienes una inyección de oxitocina y vasopresina,
que están asociados con el apego.
Es por eso que sientes tal sensación de unión cósmica con alguien
después de hacer el amor con la persona.
Pero estos tres sistemas cerebrales: lujuria, amor romántico y apego
no siempre están conectados entre sí.
Puedes sentir un fuerte apego a una pareja de largo tiempo
y sentir un intenso amor romántico por otra persona,
mientras sientes deseo sexual por gente que no tiene que ver con estas otras parejas.
En resumen, somos capaces de amar a más de una persona al mismo tiempo.
De hecho, te puedes acostar en la cama en la noche
y oscilar de sentimientos profundos de apego por una persona
a sentimientos profundos de amor romántico por otra.
Como si tuvieras una reunión de comité en tu cabeza,
como si trataras de decidir qué hacer.
Por eso no creo, honestamente, que seamos un animal hecho para ser feliz;
somos un animal hecho para reproducirse.
Pienso que la felicidad que encontramos, la hacemos
y sin embargo pienso que podemos tener buenas relaciones entre nosotros.
Entonces concluyo con dos cosas:
quiero concluir con una preocupación,
tengo una preocupación que ilustraré con una historia maravillosa
La preocupación son los antidepresivos
En los Estados Unidos cada año se expiden más de 100 millones de recetas de antidepresivos,
y estas drogas van a ser genéricas.
Están permeando alrededor del mundo.
Conozco una niña que ha estado bajo antidepresivos, estimulantes de serotonina,
antidepresivos estimulantes de serotonina desde los 13 años.
Tiene 23 y los ha tomado desde que tenía 13 años.
No tengo nada en contra de las personas que lo toman por una corta temporada
cuando están pasando por un momento terrible.
Cuando quieren suicidarse o matar a alguien;
lo recomendaría.
Pero cada vez más gente en los Estados Unidos las tomas por largo tiempo,
y en efecto, están drogas elevan los niveles de serotonina,
los cuales al subir, suprimen el circuito de la dopamina.
Todo mundo lo sabe,
la dopamina está asociada al amor romántico.
No sólo suprime el circuito de la dopamina, sino que mata el deseo sexual.
Y cuando matas el deseo sexual, matas al orgasmo,
y si matas el orgasmo, matas el flujo de drogas asociadas con el apego.
Estas cosas están conectadas en el cerebro
y cuando interfieres con un sistema cerebral,
vas a interferir con el otro.
Sólo quiero decir que un mundo sin amor es una lugar muerto.
Entonces… (aplausos)… gracias.
Quiero terminar con una historia y luego un comentario.
He estado estudiando el amor romántico, el sexo y el apego durante 30 años.
Soy una gemela idéntica; me interesa el porqué somos todos iguales.
por qué tú y yo somos iguales, por qué los iraquíes y los japoneses y
los aborígenes australianos y la gente del Amazonas son todos iguales.
Hace un año, un servicio de citas por Internet, Match.com, contactó conmigo
y me preguntaron si les diseñaría un nuevo sitio de citas.
Les dije: "Yo no sé nada sobre personalidad,
no sé, ¿creen que hablan con la persona indicada?"
Dijeron que sí.
Eso me puso a pensar por qué uno se enamora de cierta persona en lugar de otra.
Ese es mi proyecto actual y será mi próximo libro.
Hay todo tipo de razones por las que nos enamoramos de cierta persona en lugar de otra.
El momento es importante, la proximidad es importante,
el misterio es importante. Te enamoras de alguien que en cierta forma es misterioso,
en parte porque el misterio eleva la dopamina en el cerebro,
probablemente te impulse hacia el umbral del enamoramiento.
Te enamoras de alguien que se ubica dentro de lo que llamo "el mapa del amor,"
una lista de rasgos que inconscientemente armaste en la niñez conforme crecías.
Y también pienso que empiezas a
gravitar hacia ciertas personas, de hecho, con sistemas cerebrales de alguna forma complementarios
y con eso estoy contribuyendo ahora .
Les quiero contar una historia para ilustrarlo.
He tratado hasta ahora sobre la biología del amor,
quisiera mostrarles un poco sobre la cultura también…
la magia de esto.
Es una historia que me contó alguien que la había escuchado de alguien más..
posiblemente una historia verdadera.
Érase un estudiante graduado -- yo y dos colegas estábamos en Rutgers --
Art Aaron que está en SUNY Stonybrook.
Allí es donde poníamos a la gente dentro del escáner IRM.
Y este estudiante estaba locamente enamorada de otra estudiante,
pero ella no estaba enamorada de él.
Y todos estábamos en un conferencia en Beijing.
Él sabía de nuestro trabajo que si haces algo muy novedoso con alguien,
puedes subir la dopamina en el cerebro
y quizá disparar el sistema cerebral del amor romántico (risas)
Así que él decidió poner la ciencia en práctica,
e invitó a la chica a tomar un paseo en un carrito oriental con él.
Y es seguro -- nunca me he subido a uno --
pero aparentemente va por todos lados pasando autobuses, camiones
es de locura, ruidoso y emocionante.
Él calculó que esto subiría la dopamina
y que ella se enamoraría de él.
Se encaminaron, ella chillaba y lo abrazaba
y reían y pasaron un momento maravilloso.
Una hora después se bajaron del carrito,
levantó los brazos y dijo: "¿No fue fantástico?,
¡¿Acaso no era guapo el chofer?!"
(Risas) (Aplausos)
¡La magia del amor!
Quiero terminar diciendo que hace millones de años, desarrollamos tres impulsos básicos:
el impulso sexual, el amor romántico y el apego a una pareja de largo plazo.
Estos tres circuitos están profundamente integrados en el cerebro humano,
van a sobrevivir mientras sobrevivamos como especie
en lo que Shakespeare llamó: "este mortal trajín."
Gracias. (Aplausos)